sterling is probably costing somewhere
in the region about two percent of our
revenues however we got a similar saving
on costs so that there's a net impact it
was as a result of that comment coming
through in the numbers we saw her
average fare down seventeen percent in
the course of just thirty three euro
which is a phenomenal fare for traveling
public at the moment would equally costs
in a very strong position unit costs
excluding fuel down six percent of which
sterling would have contributed some of
that and in the current quarter fares
will continue to fall of that sort of
rate yeah we're anticipating furs will
be down as much as another fifteen
percent in the current quarter we're
gonna grow our passengers but by about
another nine percent there is no Easter
in this quarter was in the same time
last year and so based on the visibility
that we have we think we'll be down
approximately up to fifteen percent for
the remainder of the year now you've
been quite clear since the referendum
since the brexit vote that you're going
to shift capacity away from the UK into
other destinations well I suppose in
what we've said is that we're not gonna
grow as rapidly as we might otherwise
have done we haven't said we're gonna
actually move capacity but we won't grow
as quickly so that the terminology
removes that we would pivot some of our
growth away so where we see
opportunities in the UK such as the the
recent announcement of the extension of
our stands there deal which will see us
carry 20 million customers understands
that next year will clearly take a you
know advantage of those opportunities
and but we might not grow as quickly as
we might otherwise have done which means
with 15 percent market share and
ambitions to grow to 200 million
customers which is about 23 percent
market share in Europe the UK might can
get as much at a spy as they might
otherwise would have done now in the
statement today you also mentioned that
you've had a slight slip in punctuality
and you're putting that down to people
abusing the two free carry on allowances
yeah I mean the biggest reasons for the
the reduction in punctuality over the
winter have been ongoing air traffic
control disruptions due to staffing and
sloth delays ATC strikes and and adverse
weather but but a small portion of our
of the impacts on punctuality as well as
unfortunately people are starting to
abuse our our to bag
on board rule we've you know one of the
the best things we did on their on their
AG be one I was getting better one was
to allow people to take a second
carry-on bag on board the aircraft for
free like all good things in life people
have used this and we're not seeing
wheelie bags some instances coming on
we're seeing almost massive backpacks
coming on board and with the best will
in the world they won't fit in the
overhead bins this leads the delays at
the gates it leads to a number of bags
have to be taken off before we take off
which which you can delay the departure
so we're saying to our customers please
play by the rules it's good for
everybody it works really well and we'd
like to retain it as is but if people
continue to abuse the rules then we'd
have to look at the the two bags on
board the aircraft
you can't blame people when you're
charging them to bugging you to the hold
can you know what we do for people is
that we offer to take the bag off to mat
the case and put it into the hold and
we've been very clear you can have a 10
kilo bag on board a wheelie bag on board
the aircraft as I said a lot of people
are bringing twice three times the size
of a wheelie bag on board the aircraft
we we've got very good baggage fares you
know our average cost of our average
fare in the last quarter was 33 euro and
that includes a bag now that does
tremendous value and if people want to
go off and you know bond the number of
other packages in the form of our
leisure plus or our business plus where
they get fast-track priority boarding
twenty kilo bags well they can do that
as well at very competitive levels the
one thing we are good at is is offering
people very good value and on the bags
as well as on the actual furs themselves
all the price is fairly steady right now
yeah I mean the the OPEC production cots
announced last November it seemed to be
sticking we see a lot of people seem to
be implemented particularly in Saudi
Arabia and in Russia that said we're
well hedged into next year we've got
over eighty-five percent of our fuel
requirements locked away at about forty
nine dollars a barrel which is down from
sixty two dollars a barrel in the
current financial year so we're gonna
deliver significant savings on the fuel
line next year some of which will
inevitably go back in lower first or our
customers well we are in a better
position than a lot of our competitors
pickly the weaker guys they wouldn't
have hedging lines so while they were
the first beneficiaries of fuel dropping
they're also gonna be the first
to feel the pain as fuel prices are to
cooperate what about $57 a barrel today
I think we were in in the forties back
in November prettier the OPEC
announcement so this will have an impact
on some of the carrier's over the next
12-18 months